bella tutti ragazzi in regione ci sono
bravi già oggi stiamo su strand reed
stranded ritmi come cazzo si dice trend
è un ragazzino un giorno tipo the forest
che mi avete consigliato in massa da
quando è uscito perché uscito l'altro
george 5 6 giorni fa non lo so mi è
crollato tutto
beh ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto ora o sono uscito mita e
crociato tre volte in partenza
fantastico sono partiti da dio la
fantasia di partenza dei giochi di
sopravvivenza che appello lo zio ma tu
hai tirato solo aerei di carta o sei
pilotare un aereo perché sennò sono
problemi ha sete in due pure mica in due
non riuscito a farne uno fantastico che
è martini martini l'unico gioco della
storia dove di craftare un martini bassa
vinto tutto questo sarebbe il tutorial
fare un martini si ma perché ovviamente
quando c'è un aereo in turbolenza la
prima cosa che ti viene in mente
prendere un martin a mi sono seduto la
madonna chia ca zzo successo caduto un t
rex su styler si lega a parte il fatto
che siamo nella merda
e stato bello preparare un martini per
voi bene e stiamo per morire o cosa
perfetto
ovviamente un qualsiasi essere umano a
una cosa del genere sarebbe morto
stecchito ma ok sta roba è realistica il
300 per cento e un telefono telecomando
ed è che se che così svengo il vino la
pena bye bye bye avrà il suo veloce
veloce mio dio come cazzo fatto a
sopravvivere sulla madonna è fantastico
no vabbè ma essere se il troppo serio
sto gioco cazzo
ok
ma ci avrà un limite la sfiga di
quest'uomo cosa perfetta le classiche
giornate di merda del lunedì ma posso
già andare al 20
c'è un isola laggiù o cazzo tipo tosto
mio dio naufraghi viper prendi sta roba
perché dovresti pagaiare in acqua non
sulla prova ben sbaglio si sta muovendo
da solo nell'ombra siamo per approdare
su un'isola deserta fuck yeah maldive è
perché io prenota le vacanze nei posti
giusti
continua non si può nuotare anche sulla
sabbia chiara gado sopravvivere su
un'isola deserta non è fantastico sono
bear grylls luca ragazzi ha poi che sta
roba è fighissimo sopravvivere su
un'isola tipo ho trovato una cassa
questo trovare cos'è una bussola
ho trovato una bussola che non ai danni
che cosa mi posso servire visto che ci
sono tre metri e mezzo di terra per ok
extra che ma posso usarlo come
evidentemente non posso usarla ma posso
anche notare che figo vari capire una
cosa ragazzi ma parte la barca che non
funzionerà mai ma che cosa cazzo stai
facendo col braccio possa andare sotto
coperta serio che figura si può
sopravvivere in st isola oppure devo
sono mascia o mio dio ho trovato la la
vita ragazza torno a basso vinto il
gioco tutto vinto toolbox la nastro
adesivo io mio santo possa attaccare le
figurine o mio dio trova una tramite le
trovo cose a caso ma mi spiegate
comunque la torcia la torcia su button è
così il sogno sta vacanza proprio
fantastico trovato una porta chissà dove
porta si può entrare aria non le aprono
e che io ci entrò di testa fantastico
martello cosa cazzo
sto sto prendendo fiato vai vai fuori
madonna sto morendo simi questo mi
avvisa anche quando sto tipo iii pando
fantastico ma voglio anch'io l'orologio
che ti insegna quando stai crepando
concreti volti a [ __ ] che cazzo ci fa
uno squalo della madonna bene giorno
amico mi ha mica io son martelote lotito
sul muso ma ce la fai a scavalcare anche
bravo
via via via via via via via via via via
via via via via lucio forma in forma
dov'è dov'è dov'è lo verso via già fatta
su carlo tutto devi morire una donna che
bello tommaso palazzo la famiglia sì
l'ho preso dai cro preso ragazzi non
posso non è possibile
l'ho ucciso eccolo più bello che se
cambiamo isola che è meglio comunque ci
sono uno squalo sono realizzati in
mancanza di radio ragazzi qual cosa
dovremmo fare
c'è un cazzo extra roba o mio dio è non
scassata il cazzo no che come ti
permetti nella vita vieni qua sono pieni
come ti permetti mai fuori come ti sei
permesso di toccarmi ti denuncio no
scherzavo è schiacciante a prendere sul
personale che ho finalmente raga non
posso vivere con gli squali non è che
posso fare due metri trovarmi non scuola
davanti alla faccia comunque le pinne
oddio sole film che è figo madonna come
nuoto non l'abbiamo trovato la vita con
le pinne ma non si possono trovare che
figo ma non queste norme
madonna alta ancora aste bussola è nato
questo gioco ragazzi una cosa
incredibile
allora fa miche ma che cosa sei superman
[Musica]
io posso fare a posso tagliare
che figata della madonna ma posso
arrivare no va bene figata ragazzi sono
una scimmia o il diploma da scimmia
adesso aveva fatto rotta per l'isola
misteriosa quella più grande che vedrà
un viaggio incredibile pieno di emozioni
mozzafiato e probabilmente pieno di
squali chiara gatti mista finisco qua
perché se non ci muoviamo più faccio un
po di provvista simili ha raccolto una
vagonata di kochi pietre e cose strane
comunque una roba tipo ah ok se premo il
tasto destro e sinistro come amica kate
fire gesù ti ringrazio ce l'abbiamo
fatta a capire a devo ammettere che cosa
terra per kraft ha ma cribbio perché poi
abbiamo la spiaggia privata e ci
facciamo pagato ci posso dar foto sta
roba
se io ho fatto il fuoco madonna che
fenomeno rai martedì ma dove ho trovate
natura ma credo comunque la gara parte
come si apre il cocco
va beh qui posso fare altre cose brutte
tipo no devi metterlo via a sto cazzo di
accendino ma se io accendo un fornaio di
lele tipo un aeroplano qualcuno vero
che cazzo ne so se cucino delle cose
tipo il granchio rave a tutela anche di
me ma da visti tutti geni aver fatto il
fuoco non so come si può bruciare il
granchio mi serve qualcosa è morto che
era morto avevo capito anche prima
niente va bene lo bruciano così don
angelo sopra il fuoco finché non si
cuoce ragazzi si sta facendo buio devo
trovare una [ __ ] barca prima che
faccia buio sta diventando purissimo
merda calmo sbavano gli zombie è il mio
fuoco se alla ragazza parte sta cagata
concludo quell'episodio anche perché mi
fa un po strano nel prossimo vede
riuscire a captare qualcosa anche
buttando giù gli alberi perché non vado
non siete un cazzo porto poi col
prossimo ragazzi sperano che i primi
episodi vi sia piaciuto è un po così
perché devo capire anche io come
funziona perché la prima volta che ci
gioco o un che ragazzi mi metto qui
vicino al camino perché mi sembra giusto
ha concluso ma l'episodio sarete i
suggerimenti comunque una cosa che
volete che io faccio finché che sapete
come si fa potevo sapere nei commenti e
io comunque cercherò di dare un'occhiata
per capire cosa fare meglio la prossima
volta
molti ragazzi servito è piaciuto ma
solitamente mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come la divido tra la
descrizione forse dovresti di serafini
cimitero prossimo video vede ragazzi